do I keep going to the extreme when
we're talking about the norm I think
she's looking at staring women only
confuse the intimacy if there is a
problem
[Music]
I say that because women use it
sometimes as a weapon we do yeah yeah
and I don't think that's okay yeah
that's not okay but she's probably using
it as a weapon because there is a valid
reason but could she be not willing to
be intimate with him because just
because the butterflies are gone just
because she's like no see that's wrong
not sure
it's something really like Oh you mean
it's wrong if she does that but why do
you guys okay yeah why do we keep adding
things to avoid the actual question is
not sleeping if you're a good wife if
you refuse to sleep with your husband
that is the question it's not if you're
an abusive
it's just are you a good wife if you
won't have sex with your husband